let's go next to our caller from the
6:09 area code who's calling today from
6:09
hey David this is Boaz from New Jersey
hey Boas what's up so I just wanted to
ask you a question how long do you think
it's going to take and or what is it
going to take to completely flip the
Democratic Party to be a better
representative or middle working class
people we elected AOC representatives on
Omar and let's say we elect and Bernie
Sanders and let's say you say that for
two terms which would be great what's it
going to take to create a progressive
party and make that the Democratic Party
what do you think well what you have to
understand is that if it were just a
matter of the country being more
progressive we would have had a far more
progressive Democratic Party years ago
and that's where you have to integrate
into the analysis the effect of money in
politics and the disproportionate
outsized influence of big corporations
and money in politics because the
population has been well to the left of
the Democratic Party for a long time
when you poll people about health care
when you poll people about abortion gay
marriage the war on drugs drug
legalization even on money in politics
itself the American public is well to
the left of where our elected officials
are and so what you have to then
understand is that even though the
Democratic Party is certainly to the
left of the Republican Party because the
same corporate influences are affecting
both parties to similar degrees that is
really what is holding back the
Democratic Party simply moving to the
left there's a whole bunch of different
reforms there's no doubt that if Bernie
were to have eight years and the house
continues moving more to the left and
democratic senators are replaced with
more progressive Democratic senators of
course that's going to move the
Democratic Party to the left but to
really break the status quo you've got
to fix campaign finance
you've got to potentially put in place
term 'ln
which are also a factor that that
prevents our elected officials from just
doing what the people want rather than
figuring out well what are corporate
interest going to do when I'm up for
re-election if I do this or I do that so
there's a whole bunch of systemic change
that needs to happen in addition to
continuing to elect people that are
further to the left okay thank you very
much all right
Boaz from New Jersey great to hear from
you